really fun you got into the mega
makeover action oh yes i did um okay
well you transformed one of our teachers
gregory murray and during the pandemic
i am so proud to announce that he lost
60 pounds
gregory before
and this is gregory now
you looked so handsome but i really
believe all beauty is a feeling how do
you feel
i feel amazing
um after having lost all that weight it
has been feels so good just to be here
and just to be experiencing this entire
thing okay in a nutshell how did you do
it um my sister-in-law she inspired me
she found a great program and i was able
to adopt it and just go from there i'm
like what program
we're all trying to like
get higher and tighter what what'd you
do well it was called healthy you and it
was just a lot of like intermittent
fasting and things like that oh that
damn intermittent fasting
so it does work
wow gregory well you are living walking
proof of a true
and transformation
now wilmer will you like explain uh what
you did with sir hanson gregory the
thing that is important is just focus on
solid colors first start there before
you introduce patterns right then you
when you go to the level of difficulty
then introduce your patterns you know
but i think it's important that you go
okay listen
um warm colors together cold colors
together you know and what i was
thinking about it was that the way that
he carries himself the sneakers that he
likes to wear he likes comfort you like
comfort so it's like just
focus more on your sneakers and dress
backwards what shoes do you want to wear
and then pair the pants with those right
or pair the top widows right but one or
the other i think right gregory your mom
and dad um john and anna are here in the
audience hello
hi
um
i'd love to hear from both of you how
you feel about gregory's transformation
we are so so very proud of him um it was
a it was a journey
and he's stuck with it and he's a
dedicated person and that's why he was
also recognized as a teacher of the year
too
and gregory
as a teacher can you give us one piece
of wisdom as if we are all your students
as we go to commercial break what would
you impart on all of us uh the
importance of being kind and always try
and think about how everyone else may
feel when you're uh dealing with someone
else
i agree it goes back to the feeling
again
um
well
wilmer you have been someone as i said
before full circle who has always made
us feel so good whether it's through
your art or your humor or your humanity
and so thank you so much for coming here
and being a part of this very special
show as you are such a special person
[Applause]
well you can watch wilmer and ncis
mondays at 9 pm eastern right here on
cbs
[Music]